et notre ami aujourd'hui dans sanctions
immédiates sur boursorama c'est le
député européen modem vice président du
modem est également économiste robert
rochefort bonjour bonjour merci d'être
là avec nous on va parler évidemment de
la france et de tous ces indicateurs qui
sont quand même bien meilleure mais
avant je voulais avec vous à revenir sur
cette passe d'armes entre en gala merkel
et mario draghi
c'est assez inédit quand même pour la
chancelière allemande est bien les taux
d'intérêt qui sont très très faible
mettre les banques en danger
une critique à peine voilée à la raison
angry merkel sur le plan sur la forme
qu'elle quel est le fond de ce sujet le
fond de ce sujet c'est que les
politiques comme madame merkel qui
s'inquiètent du fait que il
les banques centrales finalement sont
les seuls aux commandes
et ça fait suite la discussion vous
aviez il ya un instant et god précédente
invités ont raison de s'inquiéter
en revanche là où ils ont tort cette
quête aux politiques de faire quelque
chose moi je ne crois pas que la
politique monétaire peut relancer la
croissance à elle seule c'est totalement
faux
la politique monétaire c'est quoi en
particulier avec le quantitative easing
ce sont des pompiers
qu'on envoie pour éteindre un incendie
et ils ont arrosé et ils continuent à
arroser heureusement qu il en fait aussi
et heureusement qu'il engagera serai là
et heureusement ils l'ont fait et lavez
vous n'avez jamais vu des pompiers en
arrosant un incendie qui reconstruisent
la maison si vous voulez reconstruire la
maison il faut des maçons des
architectes et ça c'est le bras ça
devrait être la politique économique des
gouvernements est évidemment aussi de
l'europe
or cette politique économique favorable
à la croissance aujourd'hui
malheureusement il n'existe pas c'est
bien ça le drame
et puis les états s'endettent pour pas
grand chose
donc ils peuvent dire les états
européens l'allemagne - parce qu'ils
sont les excédents mais encore qu'il
s'endette aussi mais bien entendu la
france dans l'est de la france y parlait
d'un remercie jamais juste au delà de ça
la critique est derrière et c'est ce qui
est mal vécu en allemagne c'est que
c'est un pays qui est vieillissant qui a
une forte épargne est ce que dit angela
merkel indirectement c'est que c'est ce
qui est reproché par beaucoup d'experts
allemands c'est que ça ruine les
épargnants allemands qui place
aujourd'hui en vue de leur retraite
parce que tu intéressant et les
allemands moi j'aime le peuple allemand
et j'aime l'économie allemande et j'aime
du dirigeant allemand
ils ont fait les réformes qu'il fallait
chez eux en revanche les allemands et je
ne peux pas leur reprocher défendre les
allemands et défendre d'allemagne quand
on a créé l'euro ça fait quelque temps
déjà mais vous savez très bien être les
critères de conversion ont été très
favorable à l'allemagne ça leur a permis
d'exporter d'une façon extrêmement
puissante
les allemands défendent toujours des
allemands mais contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire on peut dialoguer et on
peut négocier avec les allemands
simplement il faut en face à voir des
gens pour négocier aujourd'hui en a pas
donc madame merkel est là elle n'a pas
en face d'elle un pouvoir français qui
négocierait vraiment avec elle avec
l'objectif d'arriver à être d'accord
parce que le jour où la france et
l'allemagne seront d'accord pour une
politique économique je parle pas
monétaire c'est pas de la faire au
niveau de l'europe vous verrez ce sera
quelque chose de positif pour l'instant
ce n'est pas le cas apprenez d'abord bon
il faut aussi avoir être en capacité à
négocier via le mans est tendu une
croissance et un chômage plus faible
demande il faut faire des personnes au
delà des personnes
oui les deux jouent les deux jours je
crois malheureusement aujourd'hui qu'on
a on a à la fois comment dire une
carence de leader en termes d'hommes
d'état qui dirige la france et nous
avons en même temps une insuffisance de
réformes peut-être que l'un d'ailleurs
va avec l'autre c'est à dire et là c'est
le bilan des quatre années que nous
venons de passer au delà ma critique de
denguin merkel il ya cette idée des
effets secondaires de la politique
monétaire de la bce sur les banques qui
va y avoir de faibles marges et des mâts
et les banques en mauvais santé oms en
termes économiques distinguons l'aspect
technique et l'aspect politique
nous savons tous que n'avoir aujourd'hui
que les banques centrales aux affaires
est quelque chose qui finit par être un
poison nous n'avions pas le choix
quel est le problème en europe en europe
c'est que nous n'avons qu'une seule
institution fédérale
c'est la banque centrale européenne et
enfin ces institutions ne sont pas
fédéral et elles sont égoïstes nationale
où elles sont extrêmement faibles et la
traîne gouvernementale c'est ce que
c'est c'est le mot officiel
ça veut dire en fait renvoyant au
gouvernement donc d'un point de vue
technique
madame merkel n'a pas tort en revanche
d'un point de vue politique
draghi a raison de dire aux états
maintenant d'assumer et les états
n'assume pas et c'est bien ça la
difficulté et je trouve terrifiant que
si ça se trouve la chronique se
terminera par une mise en procès de
draghi alors que comme vous l'avait dit
il ya un instant s'il n'avait pas été là
alors là pour le coup lincendie brûlés
non seulement toute la maison mais même
les maisons autour épicier coup de main
à merkel et que 2 les taux d'intérêt
devaient doivent remonter face ils
devaient remonter pour faire plaisir aux
épargnants allemands qui se disait ruiné
je sais dans quel état serait la zone
euro et si elle supporterait les taux
d'intérêts plus élevés alors que la
croissance est quand même fait même si
elle accélère un peu et l'inflation et à
0 bien entendu mais encore une fois ce
qui nous manque
à côté d'une politique monétaire ces
deux choses c'est une politique de
convergence des politiques économiques
des états et âcre con ça depuis des
années on l'entend depuis des années
parce qu'on ne veut pas le faire parce
qu'on ne veut pas le faire et parce que
non le 10 personnes le feu et parce que
c'est dramatique
et parce que les états sont égoïstes et
à chaque fois qu'on voit des situations
ayant trait à des commandes ya du
dumping fiscal d'un état contre l'hôte
ce sont les états qui se font la guerre
je vous le dis il faut effectivement une
politique européenne et puisque vous
m'interrogez sur ce point je pense que
ça ne pourra pas partir d'autre chose
que d'une relance du couple
franco-allemand je ne crois même pas que
sur la zone euro aujourd'hui elle est
trop divisée
il faut que ce soit le couple franco
allemand vous me direz et vous aurez
raison qu'il ya des élections en france
et en allemagne l'année prochaine donc
c'est pas le moment où idéal pour que
ils prennent une grande initiative
pourtant il faudra bien le faire bon on
revient en france avec vous robert
rochefort avec des bonnes nouvelles
cette semaine on a vu une baisse du
chômage ne sont pas en discuter j'ai
sorti un communiqué comme côté technique
mais bon sur un trimestre le chômage en
france a quand même baissé de de 50000
personnes
on a eu la baisse aussi des défaillances
d'entreprises en un chiffre de la
croissance ce matin +0 25% comme une
accélération vous ergoter un petit peu
calmé je vous sens où est ce que vous
comptez faire ça je ne suis même pas sûr
vous soyez convaincus par ce que vous
dites mais attendez prenons la
croissance de ce matin ont fait 0,1 pour
cent de plus que ce qui était attendu
ouais t'as 0,5 sur un an ça fait de
placer des attendait 0,1 pour cent de
plus
on n'est même pas sûr oui mon quatrième
alarme était à 0,3 et alors et vous
savez tous et vous savez bien entendu
que le t4 de l'année dernière thé biaisé
avait été biaisée par les attentats
terroristes
donc on récupère on récupère un petit
peu ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose vous savez que ce bon
premier trimestre est tirée par la
consommation et par l'investissement qui
repart maison suez ou par la
consommation sur tout ça pèse plus
évidemment surtout par la consommation
moi je vous le dis on ne peut plus
continuer à penser que la france peut
être un pays qui tire sa ces bonnes
choses de la consommation les américains
les américains aux argos case unis c'est
la consommation qui tient le pays bays m
chauvet on dire hier la même chose je
reste en france une seconde troisième
troisième chose nous sommes dans le
moment où nous avons bénéficié à plein
du fameux alignement des planètes et ont
un intérêt en particulier de la question
du pétrole
autrement dit la question qu'il faut se
poser aujourd'hui c'est la question
suivante est ce que ce chiffre qui est
un bon chiffre sur le plan du chiffre et
ce qu'il révèle quelque chose de
l'économie française en tant que tel
investissement tout combat long de
l'investissement des entreprises a
relevé marc franchement avant le débat
alors et alors et par l'ema des deux
formations aussi oui oui pour le coup ça
pèse dingue et voilà donc donc c'était
très volatile y en a d'autres oui mais
une économie une économie se sont un
certain nombre de moteurs ce que je vous
dis simplement c'est nous avons
aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien que ce soit
une bonne nouvelle mais nous avons voyez
un peu le verre d'eau à moitié moitié
vide comme normand ce que ce que je dis
ce que je dis c'est que il faudra il
faut évidemment voir la confirmation à
venir mais ce que je dis c'est que je ne
crois pas à la capacité d'avoir une
france qui soit performante
tant qu'elle ne rétablit pas la
confiance étant quelque temps qu'elle ne
crée pas comment dire des choses qui
sa force intérieure sa capacité elle
même à produire serre comprenez des
baisses de charge 40 milliard d'euros
qui commence à se traduire en
investissements des entreprises qui pour
l'instant se traduisent en restauration
des marges en restauration des marges
il faudra qu'on voit comment ça se
diffuse dans l'économie en distinguant
les pme et les grands groupes mais la
vessie aux entreprises c'est plus
intérieure 6% en rythme annualisé ça
c'est quand même 7 % savait très bien
qu'il ya un moment un moteur qui
s'allument vous savez très bien qu'à un
moment donné où les machines
il faut les changer parce que elles sont
totalement usées on a poussé on a poussé
jusqu'au bout
ce qui compte c'est pas l'investissement
de remplacement est utile c'est
l'investissement d'avenir c'est à dire
l'investissement de croissance capacités
et celui là je vous dis excusez moi si
vous avez le sentiment que je regarde le
vert au tir vide aux deux tiers vides je
ne sais pas mais ce que je vous dis
j'aimerais que la france on puisse dire
que la croissance est repartie
je vous dis au jour d'aujourd'hui qu'il
est prématuré de le dire ainsi et que
pour l'instant nous avons bénéficié ce
trimestre alors qu'on m'avait perdu le
pré ce trimestre précédent d'un effet de
conjoncture
nous avons bénéficié d'un contexte
international - j'attends la réponse par
le pays 8 même ce alors ça ne va pas
mieux
pour le dire autrement quand j'entends
le ministre des finances dira c'est la
preuve que la politique du gouvernement
marche chez sa maman ça ce sont des
comptes pour des enfants dans un jardin
d'enfants
c'est pas c'est pas la réalité donc non
pour le ça ne va pas mieux comme le rat
l'a rappelé récemment le chef de l'état
encore ça ne va ça ne va pas vraiment
mieux alors c'est la mède nouvelle
méthode coué on nous annonce et
l'inversion de la courbe
non ça ne va pas vraiment mieux j'espère
que ça ira mieux dans quelques temps je
ne vois pas comment ça peut aller mieux
tenez prenons un autre exemple un
exemple dont on ne parle jamais est ce
que vous savez qu'aujourd'hui au niveau
intra européen
on est en train de se faire piquer
énormément de marché par les espagnols
il ya une concurrence à l'intérieur de
l'europe
on n'arrête pas de parler de l'allemagne
qui est plus performante que nous sur
les exportations mais aujourd'hui c'est
juste aujourd'hui quand vous avez à
l'intérieur de l'europe des pays qui se
réforme notamment sur la question du
marché du travail prenait la question
l'italie d'autres ils ne font forts
d'autres qui ne le font pas la france
d'autres qui ne le font pas
et bien dites vous bien que la question
à venir ce sera de regarder si
l'investissement en europe il se fait
pas dans ces pays là au lieu de se faire
en france donc je suis comment dire je
joue simplement mon rôle je suis en
train de dire non tant qu'il n'y aura
pas de réformes structurelles plus
importante en france il n'y aura pas de
retour de la confiance
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de retour de la
confiance je ne crois pas à une reprise
économique très forte je rajoute au
passage parce qu'on sait aussi on le dit
toujours que même si vous avez un pour
cent et demi de croissance cette année
n'oubliez pas qu'à côté des autres pays
nous sommes un pays dans lequel la
population croît et son regard d'un pib
par tête est bien à ce moment là vous
verrez qu'on est vraiment sûr de
l'epsilon donc non j'aimerais vous dire
autre chose
j'espère avoir argumenté pour vous dire
que pour l'instant non je ne suis pas
encore dans une situation béate en train
de dire l'économie française est
repartie
est ce que robert rochefort et béats
d'admiration devant l'accélération des
manuels macron avec la création de noms
vous souriez moins d'un coup là la
création de son mouvement ces
transgressions qui sont qui sont répétés
il prône l'effacement ou le dépassement
sur comment il faut le dire du clivage
droite gauche qu'est ce que vous retenez
de ça dont on va il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé je pense que emmanuel macron
apporte quelque chose à la gauche
je crois que si je regarde ce qui se
passe à gauche aujourd'hui je suis
peut-être un peu caricatural mais je
pense que c'est le seul qui apporte
quelque chose à la gauche quand il dit
qu'il faut dépasser sur un certain
nombre de sujets des clivages droite
gauche
je ne vais pas dire le contraire siemens
est à droite maintenant lot de midazolam
sommes au centre c'est pour ça que je ne
vous répond pas comme péter les
alliances etc à droite car je dois aux
élections intermédiaires
cette fois ci est revenu au bercail
cette fois ci cette fois ci mais nous
non non attendez c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe
être au centre ce n'est pas ne pas faire
des alliances avec d'autres par contre à
droite être cette fois ci par contre
être au centre
cela veut dire considérer que non il
n'ya pas la droite qui a 100% de
raison donc vous diego je peux
respectant même chose que maintenant je
dis je dit jeudi sur ce point précis
c'est lui qui déjeune lourd jeudi sur ce
point précis je ne vais pas comment dire
dire qu'il a tort quand il dit qu'à du
soleil quand il fait beau mais en
revanche si vous voulez savoir pour la
présidentielle à venir
je souhaite qu alain juppé salue
président de la république françois
bayrou roule toujours pour alain juppé
n'a pas changé écoutez en tout cas il ya
des primaires il ya des primaires la
droite et du centre
je souhaite qu'à la jupe et soit
emmanuel marc emmanuel macron pr
ministre d'alain juppé
votre agenda ça j'y crois pas c'est
passé le vanneau n'y croyez pas non je
n'y crois pas parce que comment dire si
alain juppé est élu il sera élu avec des
barreaux chaque dépôt de gauche avec des
voix si marine le pen tout sera élu mais
mais mais je ne crois pas que ça
voudrait dire un président de droite et
un premier league premier ministre de
gauche ça c'est ce qu'on fait en
allemagne avec le la chancelière et le
vice-chancelier
quand on est dans un système qui est un
système rpt oulalala la pièce de monnaie
tombe sur sur la sur la france ce ne
sera pas le cas en france si alain juppé
et telus pas avec les blue jackets
prochaine ce sera vous le savez bien
parce que y'aura marine le pen
probablement qualifier pour le second
tour et un autre candidat qui sera la
jupe et dont on est dans une autre
considération
si par contre et là je crois que je suis
du centre en vous disant ça si par
contre vous me demandez est ce qu'il
faut qu'un juppé ne fasse un
gouvernement qu'avec des gens de droite
je vous dirai non
il aura la responsabilité historique de
faire l' inverse de ce que jacques
chirac avait fait c'est à dire face à
jean marie le pen d'être élu lui aussi
avec des voix de gauche fait de dire bah
non finalement je fais un gouvernement
business as usual voilà ce que je pense
je prends soin des compromis ni
fondement ni veux pas être ministre
françois bayrou est allé récemment
monsieur bayrou deux choses dit une
chose qui est très simple il dit un
premier ministre doit être quelqu'un en
qui le président de la république
hameçon confiance quelqu'un de son quand
quelqu'un de son parti on sait bien que
même lorsqu'ils sont du même parti ils
ont tendance à voir des rivalités assez
forte
donc le premier ministre et le président
de la république en france c'est pas
comment dire quelqu'un qui compense
l'autre c'est normalement une équipe qui
travaille ensemble c'est plié pour vous
la primaire à droite on voit que ça
commence à bouger un petit peu entre
bruno le maire et françois fillon mais
sur les deux premiers candidats entre
nicolas sarkozy
alain juppé c'est assez cristallisé où
il n'y a rien à piller simplement qu'est
ce que nous apportons dans cette
primaire nous disons que et c'est pour
ça que les gens qui sont centristes je
crois qu'ils ont intérêt à aller voter
dans cette primaire nous disons que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir dire si alain
juppé gagne la primaire
eh bien nous ne présenterons pas de
candidat contre alain juppé alors que
s'il est pourquoi la juge oui mais si
c'est bruno le maire si c'est françois
fillon non mais françois bayrou il ira
ou pas vous êtes vraiment on verra tout
sauf sarkozy
non on verra on verra honnêtement on
peut étudier tous les cas de figure ça
peut être aussi nadine morano pourquoi
pas pendant que vous y êtes
soyons réalistes aujourd'hui ça se joue
entre deux hommes nicolas sarkozy et
alain juppé
le seul cas de figure qui aurait du sens
par rapport à ce que vous dites c'est si
nicolas sarkozy disait demain
eh bien je vais d'abord je n'y vais pas
pour l'instant pas le chemin pour
l'instant ce n'est pas ce que j'ai
retenu de ce qu'il dit mais peut-être
que j'ai pas bien compris
bon on termine là dessus robert
rochefort michel sapin qui a confirmé
cette semaine le prélèvement de l'impôt
à la source dès le 1er janvier 2018 qui
sera inscrit dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2010 est pour vous c'est
par l'économiste là et bien est-ce que
c'est d'un côté une avancée puisque la
ponction fiscale se fait en temps réel
où c'est une réforme pour rien parce
qu'il y aura toujours à remplir son
obligation déclarative ans il ya déjà la
mensualisation réforme d'écran de fumée
qui veut nous laisser croire que ce
gouvernement fait une réforme fiscale
alors qu'il ne fait absolument pas de
réforme fiscale qu'il faudrait faire et
ont dû comme il ne peut pas faire une
réforme fiscale
sur l'ensemble de la bouteille il change
l'étiquette de la bouteille mais je vous
dis simplement la chose suivante les
centristes on est intellectuellement
favorable au prélèvement à la source
mais là je vous dis gros danger gros
dans je vais favorable et là vous dit
non non je dis gros danger et et je vais
vous dire pourquoi
d'abord parce que comme parle comme
d'habitude on refile le bébé à l'équipe
d'après très très habile politiquement
de dire je fais une réforme mais non
s'il avait voulu faire ce prélèvement la
source pourquoi ne l'ont ils pas décidé
il ya quatre ans puisque c'est un sujet
qui est donc et dans les laits placard
depuis extrait est favorable mais
deuxième enfant je m'en attendais je
vous dis quelque chose là en tant
qu'économiste fait attention à une chose
le jour
il y aura le prélèvement à la source
vous allez avoir des citoyens affiche de
bien varier la fiche de paie sur la
feuille de paye vont voir leur salaires
a considérablement baissé
alors on leur dira c'est un effet
d'optique parce que ce sera récupérée
vous ne paierez pas plus mais vous savez
comme moi que l'économie c'est de la
psychologie que c'est de la confiance et
vous êtes favorable mais la politique ce
n'est pas faire une réforme à laquelle
vous êtes favorable en théorie à
n'importe quel moment
moi je vous dis si ça se fait un moment
donné où la confiance est de retour
pourquoi pas deuxièmement c'est un
élément si c'est un élément de package
dans lequel la vraie réforme fiscale est
là alors là je vous dis oui mais ce
prélèvement à la source comme un ersatz
comme une sorte d'habillage comme une
sorte de 2,2 simplement de du marketing
si vous voulez c'est elle que c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de marketing
sans conséquence puisque en plus
l'équipe qu'il propose dit c'est pas
nous qui le feront pas la patate chaude
sera il ne pense pas une seconde qu'ils
sont aux affaires dans un an
bon en même temps françois on va se
représenter ça fait quasiment aucun
doute
bon et alors bassil croix fait qu'ils y
croient encore un petit peu mais vous
savez vous savez très bien que
évidemment il suffit de mettre un
candidat y aura un candidat de gauche
mais là j'ai aussi était dans ma vie
pendant 22 ans au crédoc a regardé des
sondages de très très près ça n'existe
pas on ne peut pas remonter de la
situation dans laquelle il
c'est un fait françois hollande a trouvé
qu'ils ont perdu l'élection est perdu il
a trop déçu depuis trop longtemps et y
compris dans son propre camp
tous les experts vous diront qu'on ne
peut pas re conquérir une population
comme ça sauf évidemment événement
improbable et il était à 3% à pâques
2011 en 2011 et à 3% en oui mais pas aux
affaires il n'était pas aux affaires et
puis il s'est quand même n'a pas échappé
qu'il s'est passé quelque chose qui
n'était pas normalement inscrit dans le
calendrier politique dsk ça fait pas de
la politique des bonbons merci à vous et
robert rochefort dont que l'économiste
et député européen et vice-président du
modem merci d'arrêter notre invité en
direct sur ma peau week end